好,我们今天来聊聊台湾股市里那些顶尖的当冲高手
一讲到他们,我们脑中可能都会浮现一些传奇故事
身家上亿呀,身乎奇迹呀
但说真的,在这些神话的背后到底藏了些什么?
是他们天赋异禀,还是运气特别好?
或者是不是有一套我们一般人根本就不知道的秘密剧本?
今天我们就来把它挖出来
首先我们先来看一个数字
一个会让你下巴掉下来的数字
3000亿台币
这个不是哪家大公司的市值哦
这是一位被大家称为
台股当冲之王的巨人节
他一个人一年的交易总金额
光是这个数字就够吓人了
对吧
但更重要的是
这一切是怎么开始的
所以啦
我们真正想问的问题就是这个
这些精英交易者
跟我们这些凡人
到底差在哪里
是他们真的比较聪明
比较幸运吗
还是说
真的有一本隐藏版的剧本
是我们可以学的
很多人可能会想象
哇
要搞出这么大的事业
开头一定是一次
惊天动地的豪赌
对吧
结果完全相反
居人节
在他下出他人生的
第一笔单之前
你猜他花了多久时间
整整半年
他这半年什么都没做
没有买也没有卖
就只是每天坐在那边研究市场
这就告诉我们一件事
那些你看起来很惊人的成功
往往不是来自一瞬间的冲动
而是来自超乎常人的耐性跟准备
好
那这就带我们来到第一个
也是我觉得最关键的一根支柱
一场你看不见的心理战争
你可能会觉得很奇怪
但你听好咯
对这些顶尖高手来说
交易里最难最关键的战役
根本不是跟市场打
而是发生在他们自己的脑子里
你看我们一般人看交易想到的可能是
哇高风险的赌博很刺激
情绪跟着上上架下
好像坐云烧飞车
然后梦想着可以一戏致富
但你看另一边
对真正的高手来说
这完全是另外一个世界
每一笔交易都不是赌注
而是非常冷静的计算机率他们追求的不是情绪上的刺激而是像钢铁一样的几率他们看的更不是一个快速赚钱的捷径而是一个需要非常严谨去执行的漫长的过程
这两边的差距就是赢家跟输家的差别
这段话是少年股神MGK说的
我觉得非常有冲击力
他说
如果我的最大资金回档超过我净值的5%
我就会开始怀疑所有事情
是不是我的策略出问题了
我是不是快要被这个市场淘汰了
你静下来想一想
一个身价商议的人
对风险的敬畏跟心理上的压力
竟然还这么巨大
所以说这些高手的心理素质
我们可以把它归纳成三个基石
第一个是谦逊
就像巨人节都已经做到这个规模了
他还是每天非常痛苦的去检讨自己
做的每一笔交易
再来是情绪稳定
快乐操款人就讲过
当你觉得今天感觉不太对劲的时候
最好的操作就是关掉电脑去修食
最后是极致的纪律
就像MGK那样
不管发生什么事
都要死守自己定下的风险控管规则
没有任何例外
好 接下来是我们的第二根支柱
找到你自己的交易优势
这边有个非常重要的重点
就是这世界上根本没有什么
万用的神奇工事
真正的成功
是来自于去发展
并且精通一套
完全属于你自己的策略
A
我们直接来看一个实际的例子
这是快乐操盘人的
一招逆势放空法
第一步
识别
他会先去找出那种
连续好几天
涨得非常疯狂
中间完全没有休息的股票
第二步
确认
他会去观察
成交量是不是突然爆出一个超级天亮
这通常就代表最后一批散户冲进来了
然后空单也被迫回布
第三步等待
他会非常有耐心的等
等到那个反转的讯号出现
那通常是尾盘的时候
骨架突然啪一声撑不住了
第四步执行
就在那个瞬间果断出手
去抓住后面那段恐慌性脉压的动能
你看这整套流程背后是一套非常严谨的逻辑而不是凭感觉在乱猜嗯很多人会把这种很精准的判断归功于一个亲切牙很玄的词
叫做盘感
但盘感到底是什么东西
它真的不是什么神秘的天赋哦
它其实是一种透过海量的重复的练习
最后锻炼出来的肌肉记忆
你可以想象一下
在行情很热的时候
一天可能要做上千次的买卖决定
那种几乎不用经过大脑思考
像是反射动作一样的反应
就是盘感真正的来源
那讲到风险管理
MGK有一个观点
听起来非常反直觉
他说错误的停损比不停损更可怕
诶等一下这句话什么意思啊
难道是叫我们不要停损吗
不不不
他的意思是一个真正有效的停损
他的判断标准远比你设定一个固定价格
要复杂的太多了
所以一个更聪明的停损机制
看的根本就不只是价格
MGK有提到
整整会让他决定出场的警讯
可能是像这些
第一流动性风险
他发现这只股票
快要被主管机关抓去关紧币了
到时候会很难卖掉
或者整个市场的氛围改变了
原本大家在说的上涨故事
突然讲不通了
还有更细微的
他会一直盯着那个五档挂单
如果他发现
原本挂在下面那几张超级大的买单
突然咻不见了
这就是一个非常强烈的讯号
代表背后的主力
详话改变了
好我们来到第三根支柱了
持续的进化
这一点真的非常非常重要
因为一个交易者
他必须要随着自己钱的规模
还有市场环境的变化
不断去调整自己的策略
这样才能活下来
而且越活越好
对于这种进化
MGK用了一个
我觉得超级传神的比喻
他说
当你没鞋穿着时候
你什么都敢做
可是一旦穿上了鞋
你突然就变斯文了
这句话
哇
真的完美地讲出了那种
从一个赤脚拼命的交易者
变成一个需要保护自己资产的
穿鞋者的时候
那种从骨子里透出来的巨大转变这种转变在交易的世界里有一个专有名词叫做眼镜式风险轮廓讲白话一点就是你的钱越多你的玩法就必须跟着改变
你的目标不能再是
以前那种追求极致成长
开高杠杆的模式了
你必须要转变成
优先考虑
如何保住你的资本
从这张图你
就可以看得很清楚
MGK的进化过程
你看左边
赤脚阶段的它
住上一个拼命三郎
目标只有一个
用最开的速度让资产翻倍
所以他会把杠杆开到最大
专门去找那种最高风险
最高回报的机会
但你看右边
当他穿上鞋之后
他完全变了个人
从攻击手变成了守门员
目标是保本
方法是全面降低风险
玩的策略
也变成更稳健的避险啊
配对交易啊
你看哦
赚钱的方法跟守钱的方法
是完全不同的两回事
好的综合了心理策略
还有进化者三根支柱
我们终于可以拼凑出这一份
隐藏在众人眼前的
真实的交易剧本了
所以那些真正的秘密
到底是什么
这就是顶尖交易者的剧本
其实秘密都藏在细节里
第一先搞定你自己的心理
纪律和情绪控制是入场券
没有这个后面都不用谈
第二打造你个人的优势
透过relentless
也就是永不停止的练习
找到并且魔力那一把只属于你的武器
第三要像个偏执狂一样去管理风险
你要记住你的存活是取决于你怎么处理亏损
而不是你抓到多大的获利
第四要持续进化你的策略
永远要记得帮你赚到第一桶金的方法
很可能不是能帮你守住财富的方法
最后也是最重要的一点
成功是一个过程
这里没有捷径
只有刻意的专注的日复一日的努力
那么听完这些顶尖交易者的故事之后
最后我想留给你一个问题
也请你诚实的问问你自己
在你现在的策略或是思维当中
那个最大的漏洞究竟是什么
较到它或许就是你通往更高层次的第一步